hey guys it's just McDowell here with
another GS news update to fill you in on
all the good stuff about super smash
brothers from today's Nintendo Direct
presentation the fighter will land on
3ds in summer of this year and we you in
winter Nintendo have confirmed that it
will run at 60 frames per second on the
3d are those some assist trophies will
animate at 30 you'll be able to play
online or locally but as for the former
you can either elect to do so for fun or
for glory perf unnerve selects a random
stage with all items smash battles and
only wins are recorded while in for
glory mode all battles are on final
destinations there's no items you can
have one-on-one battles and both wins
and losses are recorded there's no
anonymity in online matches anymore
which means players being bad people can
get temporary Vance % badness there's
also a skill based matchmaking system
called the global smash power and the
committee s will come with an exclusive
ball player smash run mode the features
are dungeon to explore and an all-out
battle at the end as for the bosses
you'll be facing up against they'll
include the yellow devil from Mega Man
and relief from Metroid if a teasing
cameo is to be believed returning
characters include chic and zero suit
samus who will both now be standalone
characters in addition to Yoshi we also
got word on two new characters both of
them pokemon charizard and brew ninja
brawl the news about Nintendo Direct and
super smash brothers be sure to keep it
tuned to gamespot